hallo mein name ist luca und viele von
euch hassen mich also ich glaube
wirklich alle deswegen solltet ihr
weltspitze ein paar videos zu senden um
mir genau zu zeigen wie sehr er mich
hasst fangen wir schon direkt mit dem
ersten video
ich hab gesagt er soll mir sagen wie
sehr er mich hasst nicht wie ihr main
kanal de abonniert haben wir machen wir
weiter mit dem zweiten video wenn sich
kraftvoll geknackt komisch nachdem ihr
jetzt circa anderthalb millionen videos
gesendet wurden die main kanal die
abonnieren dann hätte ich jetzt nur
abonnenten ihr wurden auch videos von
meinen stickern geschickt iding outfit
was kannst du eigentlich um das ganze
mal wirklich sinnvoll zu beantworten ich
habe ja an meinem geburtstag in einem
shop 1000 unterschiedene sticker dahin
gepackt und ja wenn man 1000 sticker
unterschreibt und luca heißt kauft man
sich natürlich noch einen edding der ist
mir bei den letzten fünfzig autogramm
wirklich so ein bisschen ja sieht man
glaube ich das tut mir leid wenn ihr
wollt könnt ihr einfach noch mal luca
shop bestellen wenn ich noch mal
unterschreiben
hier ist sogar auch noch ein schönes
video von dem sticker
ja ja jeder hasst nicht sondern meine
mutter kommt einfach ich will es auf
jeden fall super cool dass ihre sachen
im buch shop bestellt und dafür diese
sticker bekommen wenn ihr allerdings so
was damit macht denke ich mir dabei
einfach nur ja ich denke ich mir dabei
gott gar nichts kommen wir jetzt zum
nächsten video wo eventuell wie ich ein
bisschen konstruktive kritik an einem
kanal geäußert wird davor was ist denn
da die nachbarn denken so ein typ
schreibt auch sonst hätte luca chance
mit tesafilm macht zum runterklappen in
your face praktisch das durchtrennen zum
ball kommt schweißt es raus ich muss das
amt der einen stelle nochmal ansehen
werner 1000 leute ja ich habe peter zu
falls jemand der markt eigentlich auch
wie kann es sein dass du in jedem video
an der stelle muss ich wirklich sagen
dass es mir selber schon mal aufgefallen
das tut mir leid und ich versuche daran
zu arbeiten dass du eben jeden video das
ist zu hören ist jetzt deine freunde
treffen
stimmt das ja gar keine freunde
luca ich habe das hier
du hast es in den schlussfolgerungen ist
halt das duo ob es korrekt mann du hast
sogar eine reihe mit eingebracht das
finde ich tatsächlich sehr toll ich habe
gar nicht die luft angehalten und ich
wollte auch richtig rot und jetzt gerade
richtig schwindlig pizza hast dich du
sagt luca seine videos und so schlecht
die werden als sterbehilfe benutzt wir
nutzen eine sache die tatsächlich im
heutigen lukas einsendungen video video
video noch gar nicht erwähnt wurde was
ist um gezielt kraft klasse haben wir
noch mehr von diesen tomatensaft
einsendungen hatten das thema des
heutigen videos war es ihr mich hasst
und mir gründe nennen sollen warum das
so ist und du bist du deine videos sind
scheiße aussehen das scheiß alles ist
scheiß automaten sagt tomatensaft ist
jetzt haben wir den lukas schon
verbundene tomatensaft findet ihr könnt
wirklich immer geile brücken schaffen
zwischen zwei verschiedenen themen zum
beispiel der hass von luca auf einer
ebene tomatensaft nicht wirklich nein du
bist scheiße ich hab ja auch noch rum
liegen von kind aber es scheint es nicht
klappt es auch nur ich weiß nicht wieso
habe ich das worauf kommen wir jetzt
auch schon zum letzten video meine damen
und herren
ich wollte eigentlich so eine stille
sequenz machen um eine depression so ein
bisschen darzustellen aber meine
schwester 50 grad die haare
deswegen hört man dass auch ich würde
trotzdem sagen meine damen und herren
denn wieso klatsche ich in letzter zeit
immer wenn euch das video gefallen hat
würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen ich sehe immer wie ihr diese fan
einsendungen luca reagiert darauf videos
total feiert falls ihren thema für das
nächste video nächstes wochenende haben
wollt die kommen übrigens immer nur am
wochenende weiter wochenende wenn man
meinen eltern zu hause bin und deswegen
kann ich die dann hier ganz cool drehen
und schneiden und